hi guys so I'm in Norway I posted this
on my main channel to let you guys know
that I'm having a meet-up tomorrow
Thursday October 13th at the Oslo Opera
I'm pretty excited I'm gonna put a link
in the description so you can check out
the Facebook page and be hanging out
with my Opera browser friends but it's
not at the Opera browser offices it's
the Opera House there's a little bit of
confusion on the water on the water
anyway I'm really excited I hope that a
lot of you guys can come and know I'm
not coming to Sweden because that's
pretty much all you guys keep telling me
to do I'm here so you guys need to come
here next time next time I'll be back go
visit you guys wherever you want me to
go anyway Facebook link description and
the band-aid
GameStop most famous Norwegian clothing
line ever you'll get some warm clothes
because we're gonna go hike glaciers
okay anyway I love you guys hope see you
tomorrow at 6 p.m.
peace out